Congressman Jorge Santos
says he is innocent
of the latest reported allegation
against him.
The finances of the Long Island
congressman are under federal
and local investigation.
He's also the subject of a House ethics
committee investigation, as you know.
Now he's accused of orchestrating
a credit
and debit card skimming operation
in Seattle involving ATMs back in 2017.
Randi Kaye has details.
I was an asset in helping
take down a ring of criminals.
New York
Congressman Jorge
Santos denying allegations
from a man from Brazil,
painting him
as the mastermind
of a credit card scheme.
I'm innocent.
I never did
anything of criminal activity.
And I am no mastermind of that.
Santos claims of innocence
are in response
to this sworn statement
by the man, Gustavo Ribeiro Trillo.
In his declaration
first published by Politico
Trevor alleges
that Santos taught him how to clone
ATM and credit cards
and that the two had agreed
to a 50 50 split of proceeds.
Trello wrote in the Declaration.
Santos gave me at his warehouse
some of the parts to illegally skim
credit card information
right after he gave me the card
skimming and cloning machines.
He taught me how to use them.
Trevor has reportedly
submitted his declaration
to the FBI
and other federal
law enforcement officials.
Santos, meanwhile, told reporters today
he wasn't the organizer
but the guy who helped crack the case.
Then I cooperated with
Secret Service, FBI.
Everybody that asked for my help
got information for them.
Got everybody arrested and deported.
I'm not the mastermind of the story.
This all goes back to 2017.
When Trello pleaded guilty
to access device fraud
in Seattle,
Federal Records
show Trevor had been arrested
after using a credit card skimming device
and electronic camera on ATMs
to steal credit and debit card numbers
as well.
As ATM pin numbers,
according to court documents.
Politico reports that in 2016
a year earlier, Trevor
had rented a room in Santos's
Winter Park, Florida, apartment.
When asked about this,
Santos quickly
distanced himself from Trello.
It was never my roommate
never left with me.
I saw him maybe a couple of times
in my life. Yet back in 2017.
According to audio obtained by CNN,
Santos appeared in court
on Triller's behalf.
At that court hearing,
Santos described Triller
as a family friend.
In court,
Santos also lied to the judge
about where he worked.
What do you do for work or fishing?
I work for Goldman.
If you work for Goldman Sachs,
in New York.
The congressman has since acknowledged
he never worked directly
for Goldman Sachs.
The investment
giant CNN has not verify
the authenticity of Triller's declaration
and Triller's attorney has not responded
to CNN's repeated phone calls and emails.
CNN has also reached out to the FBI
and the Department of Justice
for comment.
The allegation against Santos comes
as the freshman congressman
is already facing intense
scrutiny over fabrications
about his biography and resume.
Local and federal prosecutors
are also investigating his finances.
The House
Ethics Committee is also looking into
whether Santos
may have engaged in unlawful activity
during his successful 2022 campaign.
I'm very confident
I can fight this when it's very easy.
Randi Kaye, CNN.
A group of
New York Republican congressmen recently
introduced a bill that would ban
House members
like Santos
from profiting off book, movie
or TV deals
if indicted
or convicted of certain crimes
like financial and campaign
finance fraud.
Just before airtime,
I spoke to one of those members,
Congressman Brandon
Williams, who has also called for Mr.
Santos to step down
Congressman Williams,
I appreciate you joining us.
I wonder what your reaction was
to these allegations
that Congressman Santos
was involved in this credit card scheme.
Well, I tell you, it
you know, I guess it was an ATM scheme.
It looks like it's been yeah.
He's been using the
you know,
it looks like he's been using
Nassau County donors as ATMs
and he just upped his game.
So I think it's a continuation
of a frankly, of a big confidence scheme.
Very much like Bernie Madoff.
And it's all being exposed.
So the fact that his deception goes
much farther back doesn't
surprise me at all.
I mean, if the allegations are true,
they were made in a sworn statement
by the person
who was actually prosecuted
for involvement in this A.T.M.
scheme.
It's a pretty complex operation.
I mean, it involved it
according again, to this
person who was was convicted
in a warehouse in Florida
being taught by Santos
how to use the equipment,
sending him to Seattle
where they would split the proceeds.
50 50.
Can you
imagine how excited, you know, Mr.
Santos must be
or must have been to realize
that he could,
you know, do something on a larger scale,
even running for Congress,
not once, but twice.
You know, remember that Bernie Madoff
cheated a lot of very sophisticated
people out of their money.
And I think that George Santos
has cheated a whole lot
of sophisticated voters
out of their vote.
Do do you have much confidence
in the in the ethics process
in the in the House?
Obviously, this has been forwarded
to the Ethics Committee.
I don't know if they'll look
at these
additional allegations as well
or if they'll have to just wait
for to see if law enforcement
does anything.
Well, I'm
confident of a couple
of things, Anderson.
I'm confident
that leadership has taken the steps
to initiate
this ethics
investigation, that it will be thorough.
I'm actually confident
that the FEC similarly will do
its investigation
and appears
like there's a lot to look at there.
I know that Nassau County
prosecutors are also looking
and I
guarantee you
that they will do a very exceptional job.
And I'm confident
that we're going to see
George Santos in handcuffs
in front of a judge hopefully not
just to distant future.
Well, you really believe that?
I do. Absolutely.
Do you think he's getting any work done?
I mean, you know how difficult it is
being a congressperson,
all the different things
going on,
all the responsibilities you have
if you care
about the people in your district,
which I mean,
can he actually get anything done?
Well, I think I know that
his neighbors like Anthony Esposito,
Nicola Loder, Nicole Malliotakis,
they've all opened up their offices
for constituents,
you know, on Long Island
and in the vicinity
to use their offices
for whatever services are needed.
So I think there's been
a lot of help
offered in in terms of his role.
He's not on any committees.
He's not very popular.
I can tell you that
and I'm not sure what,
you know,
what work that he might be getting done.
What concerns me, Anderson, is that
he still has a security clearance and
and therefore, as a member of Congress,
is actually entitled
to briefings that involve top secret
information That concerns me a lot.
And I think that needs to be looked at.
It's also the last
thing Republicans
need, distracting people from what,
you know, everybody in
Congress is supposed to be doing.
Well, I would say the the issue
that I'm most concerned with
is that the people of Nassau County
are the victims here and their victims
because they were defrauded
out of the right to be represented.
I think the house is also the victim.
And
so those are the things that are
sort of top of mind when I think about
what's happened with George Xenos.
Had you run into him at all?
I mean, have you said anything to him
ever? I bumped into him on the floor.
And I have to tell you, it's awkward
because
because he was part
of the New York delegation.
I never met him in person until
until we were an orientation
my wife and I extended
the hand of friendship as we did.
You know, all the new members. And,
you know,
within probably a week or two
that the wheels started coming off.
And I found that pretty disappointing.
Yeah.
Well, Congressman Williams,
I really appreciate your time tonight.
Thank you. Yes, sir. Thank you.